the tornado sirens went off probably
thirty seconds ahead of it we just got
in the basement and the tornado hit took
two minutes it came with a real blade
wouldn't fifteen minutes and was here
and gone it's an experience we hear
about all too often tornado survivors
describing how the powerful storms
seemingly come out of nowhere minutes
can mean the difference between life and
death
and while advances have been made in
detecting tornadoes forecasters are
still unable to predict exactly when and
where a twister will touch down turning
to copal is here with the effort to
increase the warning time Tony good
morning good morning researchers at four
universities are working to improve
forecasting by using drones the autumn
and aircraft can do what the rest of us
cannot flying into the heart of
dangerous weather systems to collect
data on the storms 13 minutes that's the
average time between the detection of a
tornado forming - when it touches down
leaving people in its path
scrambling to find a safe place look at
the Condon site coming up this countdown
was a reality for parts of the Midwest
and South earlier last week as severe
storms and tornadoes battered the areas
leaving at least 14 people dead
unlike other weather systems tornadoes
formed quickly are hard to predict and
even harder to track
Jamie Jacob and his team from Oklahoma
State University are working on a set of
drones designed to fly into and analyze
severe weather systems meteorologists
are very good at predicting how us when
and where the storm is going to develop
but not so good at determining when a
storm is going to form a tornado at a
particular place or a particular time
they're built to withstand rain hail and
winds of at least 80 miles an hour and
they drop a device called a drop zone
that collects data from inside a
potential tornado so the goal is be able
to get more data that feeds directly
into those models and do that in real
time that real-time data can be a key
factor in saving lives when a tornado is
beginning to form we can get to the
point where we can warn an hour ahead of
time
the drones need a few more years of
testing before being put to use by the
National Weather Service the technology
is a little ahead of the regulatory
processes however so we may have to wait
for the the legal side to catch up with
us and there's still some technical
difficulties they're working on right
now the drones aren't ready at a
moment's notice it takes about four
hours of prep time so I guess you need a
forecast for the forecast drone and it
probably gonna do it yeah it's easy to
make fun of weather forecasting and
weather prediction however when you
think about technology that has saved
lives over the last five or six decades
this is a big one yeah this is huge
the regulatory infrastructure does need
to catch up and as it does in so many
other arenas to get those drones
actually out there and I remember when
the tornado dropped out of the sky and
my first job in Oklahoma and I'll tell
you you need out of nowhere and you
never forget it I need a couple thanks
for being here